bachelor colton accused of stalking his
ex
he just jumped harassing
sending unsettling text messages and
even allegedly
placing a tracking device on her vehicle
that's what cassie randolph claims
colton has done
since their breakup in april and she was
just granted a temporary restraining
order i've been very open with my mental
health it's been a struggle
the bachelor star who's dealt with
anxiety and depression
must now stay 100 yards away from cassie
after the 25 year old submitted photos
of that tracking device
and screenshots of their alleged texts
cassie claims colton sent
this after being spotted outside her
bedroom window at two in the morning
quote i'm sorry for putting you in a
weird spot last night it wasn't
appropriate
i was almost pushing her away by trying
to bring her closer
in march colton admitted to e.t that he
pressured cassie
causing them to break up briefly before
they split for good i'm saying like
no we'll be fine we'll be engaged by
this date we'll do this we'll do this
we'll do this and it was sort of
overwhelming her all over again
our source says the exes were initially
trying to stay friends
even working on a potential reality show
about their relationship
and breakup but this situation with
colton cemented the show
not moving forward cassie's family i
have to thank because they sort of
literally nursed me back to health the
former nfl player who stayed with
cassie's parents while recovering from
kovitt earlier this year
has also been ordered to stay away from
their home a hearing is set for october
6th
colton's rep wouldn't comment but we're
told cassie is upset by the situation
and trying to move forward